There are a lot of things here.
There's ten different rooms, but within each room and zone,...
...there are multiple different areas.
You've got your dream house.
Within the dream house, there's three separate sections:...
...Barbie's living room, her office and closet and her kitchen.
She's got her deck and pool.
She's got the camper van as well as Central Park,...
...the Barbie Interstellar Airways, Barbie laboratories,...
...the music production studio,...
...the fashion runway, the interior design studio.
The list goes on and on.
I couldn't stop.
We'd be here all day.
They have different things from every era.
So every time you see something from your era as a child,...
...it brings you back to that time that you were there...
...and then all the new bright things are just, it's fantastic.